[Music]
Justin Bieber just went there he's
poking fun at Taylor Swift's post
surgery banana moment it seems Bieber's
wife Haley got a kick out of the whole
thing she's the one behind the cam that
was so funny this all went down on
Justin's Instagram live over the weekend
and here's the back to back of Justin's
version verse Taylor's actual version
[Music]
what do we do with this now yeah now
it's unclear if justin is just being
funny or actually taking a swipe at
Taylor the two have had a bit of a rocky
relationship when Taylor went on her
tumblr rant against Justin's manager
Scooter Braun she said she felt like
scooter and Justin had bullied her on
social media before and we know Taylor
still has issues with scooter buying her
old label Big Machine I think that
artist deserved to own their work
starting November 2020 so next year I
can record albums 1 through 5 all over
again so
[Applause]
about it but her feud with Justin goes
much further back I think we all
remember this backstage moment at the
2013 of Billboard Music Awards but just
because I'm feeling nostalgic there was
a time when Taylor and Justin were
actually pals remember Punk'd hey you
just got positive memories anyways why
do you think Justin reenacted Taylor's
banana moment let me know and for
everything Taylor and Justin make sure
you stick with all things et until next
time I have Katie Krauss and bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]